(upbeat hip-hop music)
- [Man] How can I have
the ability or opportunity
to give value or have
someone who has everything?
- Nobody has everything and nobody has
everything at every moment.
So it's about listening.
Most people that wanna give to somebody
that has everything wants
to give on their terms.
The reason I win is cause I listen
and I give to people what they need.
Giving what you want that person
to take from you isn't giving.
It's manipulating what you selfishly want
from that person so the
answer to your question
is you gotta fuckin' listen.
- How can I talk to people
that are older than me
and get them to respect
or value an opinion?
- Just, you're not gonna convince them,
especially if you're
askin' for money, so--
- I don't want it, I just want,
I guess validation and wisdom from people
that are older that have
experienced what, you know.
- Done what you've done?
- Right.
- You just gotta ask,
you gotta ask 154 people
on LinkedIn and three will say yes.
- Our profession's like
super active on social
so I've been listening for like two months
and it's like I got a bunch of shit to do
and I don't know what it is
to do, you know what I mean?
Like I don't know where to focus it,
like I'll do like, oh
yeah podcast would be cool
but it's like I don't really
know if that's our thing
and it's just like--
- Facebook and Instagram.
And really Facebook.
The big key is the volume of content,
watch what I do not what I say.
- Right, yeah.
- Got it?
- Literally like once a
week I go to my LinkedIn,
I click on yours and I scroll down
and say this is what he's doin',
this is what he's doin'.
- That's it, watch.
That is how you will get the answers.
It's kind of like pushups or eating right,
I'm giving it to you,
it's just not that easy
to eat really well and
fuckin' work out every,
you know what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is why it really starts here,
cause the biggest thing
you have to figure out
is you're gonna be in fucking patient zone
for the next two years.
- [Man] Yeah, I'm good with that.
- Good.
- I know you always talk about legacy
and the ripple effect that
you're hoping that you have,
what we're doing, if we're successful,
is gonna save a lot of people's lives.
- That makes me super happy.
- I thought you might like that.
- I appreciate that.
- As we continue to work on
this, one of my next goals
is I wanna be able to eventually go out
and help other businesses
grow and like help them.
- I highly recommend,
this is a big fear of mine
is that so many people see
me make that transition
and don't realize that it was 15 years.
So I'm just saying, that if you're only
two years into this and
you're gonna save lives,
even though you may have that ambition,
I understand how sexy it is, do it first.
And I would say like, minimally,
like put an eight year cap on,
like those words never came outta my mouth
for 15 years, does that make sense?
- We're in healthcare,
so it's a little bit like
- I get it, but the second you're thinking
about that part, you're
vulnerable on your first part.
Every second I built my library,
there was never a part of me that thought
that GaryVee would exist.
- So should I just focus solely
on documentary and just--
- A hundred percent, build.
That will be your leverage, otherwise
you're like every other fucking guy.
- I don't wanna be like every fucking guy.
- Then fucking build an actual business
and put one hundred
thousand percent into that
and don't worry about the
consulting other businesses part,
which is so seductive
to the macro right now.
- What would you say is the best way
to try to break into
retail because I feel like
it's innovative, it's a patent pending,
nothing on the market.
- To win on Amazon and Shopify.
That's the reverse of what
people don't understand.
- Yeah, cause I'm thinking
Bed, Bath, and Beyond.
- The way to break into
Bed, Bath, and Beyond
is to show them you won on Amazon.
- Really?
- Yes.
- I had it reversed.
- Everybody has it reversed,
that's why I always win.
Everybody always has it reversed,
they let somebody else have the leverage,
I never do.
- [Man] I only heard of you
since like three days ago.
- Wow!
- [Man] Yeah.
My friend sent me here, I'm actually
not from a very good background,
my dad is an alcoholic,
my mom's a gambler,
I'm trying to get out of
that situation, right?
I did poorly in high school
because of my parents, right?
So I'm trying to start up my
life, in terms of my career.
- If you say, "I did poorly in high school
"because of my parents",
there's something interesting.
You may in hindsight, in years to come
when you get older, see
it as a huge advantage.
When I hear stories of
that much adversity,
the amount of people that I
know that have gone on to shine,
first of all, for you to be this young
and have the aspirations to break through,
instead of dwell and be like,
"I got fucked, it's over."
Huge.
- Thank you.
- I think if you keep building on that
and I actually think
being bad in high school
is foundationally a core reason
most people end up being successful
and so the more you start thinking
about your adversities as strengths,
the more the reality of what you're trying
to achieve is gonna happen, keep going.
- [Man] I'm trying to, I
can't get into college,
I really want to get into college, right?
- Why?
- [Man] So I can get a degree,
to get a job, so I can have a foundation.
- There's a really good chance that
that's not what is gonna happen.
First of all, you're gonna collect debt,
you're gonna go to college, collect debt,
and unless you go to a top 5% school,
the jobs that are available to you
on the back end of that are garbage.
- [Man] So in terms of
progressing forward,
to make an obstacle a
door, what should I start
having a base amount
of money so I can start
developing myself as an entrepreneur?
- I think the biggest thing that a kid
with this much hard luck
needs to think about
is similar to two kids
you're looking at right now,
which is can you attach
yourself to a good situation
where you pay your dues
to build a foundation?
If I'm you, I try to get attached
to a top 5,000 entrepreneur,
you already fuckin' ate dirt
because of your family situation,
eat dirt for three more years
bein' somebody's assistant,
get into the ecosystem
of real fuckin' college
or entrepreneurship which is being close
to somebody who's doin' it.
Your biggest advantage is that
you're willing to live like shit
which means you don't need a lotta money,
which means you can work
for basically for dick
for somebody who's really done it,
and if she or he sees that
you've got it, you'll win.
That's the biggest fuckin' piece of advice
I could give to a kid
who's got a shit situation.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
- How do I get out of analysis paralysis,
cause I'm not perfect but I wanna be
and like I said I see you say,
"Just go, just go, just move, just do it."
- You're valuing other people's opinions.
My question is why do you look so sharp?
Do you love it or do you think
it projects something to other people?
You gotta figure that out.
The only reason people overthink
is cause they worry about the judgment.
I go fast because I don't give a fuck.
For real, like for fuckin' real.
- See and I wouldn't mind
goin fast but only with things
that I just really really know and grasp.
- And you should do it
and if you don't know it,
hedge it up front.
You can start a video with like,
"I'm not sure what the fuck
I'm talkin' about, but boom."
Got it?
- So just preface it
and just keep it goin', keep it moving.
- That's it.
- Wow, thank you so much.
- Cause doing's that game,
if you're not doing, nothing's happening.
- Right and I don't wanna talk no more.
- Everyone's talkin' and thinkin'.
- So, we're into health and nutrition
and so we've been converting a bunch of
our family and friends cause
they all wanna lose weight,
we're trying to go for cold leads
but we feel like it's so random
that we've just been targeting people
who do like similar programs
but we don't know the,
like who to, what's the best way--
- So let me ask you a question.
You guys are trying to get
people into your program?
- Yes.
- Facebook ads.
- Yeah, we've been doing Facebook ads,
we've been doing Instagram sign-ups,
but we're talking about
the small scale of it.
- Oh okay, well the key is, you can target
on Facebook and Instagram
for such low money,
it doesn't matter what I'm
gonna tell you right now,
you need to try everything
at 25 bucks apiece,
until you find something.
- Okay, I've been tryin'
everything like transformations.
- Couple things, everybody
does the body shed,
so that's already a problem
but this is where creativity matters,
it's the reason you're wearing this jacket
and everybody wants to sell you a jacket,
so maybe one big picture of an arm flab,
one big picture, I
haven't seen that as much
and what if that woman really
fuckin' hates her arms?
- [Woman] Right, okay.
- Everybody's doin the same shit,
look how good I look, you can be like me,
that's what every fucking person does.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Which means it's hitting nobody
but even this I like better already
cause at least it's different
and it probably didn't
do as well in likes,
but that's not what matters
when you're trying to sell something.
- Okay, what matters
if likes don't matter?
- Well likes don't matter cause
you're tryin' to sell programs.
You know who fuckin' liked this?
Dudes liked this.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, not our ideal client.
- Yeah, you're right.
- I know I'm right, now I'm trying
to get you hyped enough to
fucking do what you need to do.
I would put out a post
of both you talking, say
"We would like to speak to 400 women
"who are not happy with
their health situation.
"DM us your phone number,
we will call you."
Then you take fuckin' a month and listen
and then you figure out
what to make content.
- Brilliant.
- I love it!
- Understand?
- Brilliant.
- Thank you, can we get a selfie with you
before we go?
- Yes.
Hey guys, thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me,
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy,
this project means the world to me,
I could really use your support.
(upbeat hip-hop music)